the royals 23 year old right-hander
carlos hernandez making his first major
league start he has had two strong
performances out of the bullpen let's
hope the best for him
a swing and a miss and carlos hernandez
makes quick work of the pirates in the
first for kansas city tonight when
maryfield will lead it off against
right-hander trevor williams yeah trevor
looking for some consistency
hits that one pretty well that's deep to
left and that ball is a goner home run
with merrifield one-nothing royals
williams tries to force seamer in you
can't sneak a piece of cheese by a
hungry win oh man that's just a nice
easy swing
and jacob stallings receives that
fastball cut on and missed just above
the zone and monday strikes out one out
224 now that average creeping up five
homers 16 rbis
this ball hit deep to left and josh bell
rings
your bell with that opposite field home
run his sixth you know
for some guys maybe not taking batting
practice is a good thing
no betting practice yesterday got three
hits and a home run no bad at practice
today
one for one with a home run
sent deep to center field and anchor
down dead central
clearing the deck with a cannonball is
brian reynolds and the pirates now lead
2-1 yeah that was a
nice impressive home run dead center
field
and he blows him away with a 97 mile an
hour fastball
deep to right field and out goes frazia
another home run
and it's three to one
speed about that that was 96 miles an
hour maybe not quite where he'd been
thrown earlier but frazier just jumped
all over that that's his fifth reese
solo shots for the pirates
there's a little flare to right field
for a hit
will stay put he is two for two
swing it away
go ball that ball is carrying
go yes
and it is a goner a home run by
adolberto monteci his fourth this week
the royals have tied it at three monday
all of a sudden carrying the team on his
shoulders
the fastball that time and strikes out
so that's the first out of the inning
and franco will come to bound with the
bases clear
well maybe he'll strike out twice more
tonight
as franco does right there
threw a little two seamer down and in
and that's the second out so
back-to-back case for williams three
tonight tough out to get with murryfield
has led the major leagues in hits
back-to-back seasons 2018 and 2019.
but
williams gets the tough out strikeout
and he's got to base it to right field
so a two-hit game for monday
the guy who leads the major leagues in
stolen bases at first opponents are
three for three in stolen bases against
williams this year
monday goes pitch in the dirt and he's
done it that's three straight games with
a stolen base and a home run for alberto
mondesi
couldn't have shot him out with a cannon
up the middle that's a base hit mondasi
is going to have to hurry
reynolds has a good arm he's going to
bring it back to second
and the royals take the 4-3 lead
out in front of the mound here comes
perez they flip it home and salve is
going to score and dozier and gordon are
both going to advance a terrible flip
throw
by the pitcher williams
how about salvador perez coming home on
that on three and two
don't let him call you out anything
close be aggressive be ready to hit
in the air this will be deep enough to
score dozier catch is made by reynolds
dozier advancing and gordon goes second
to third
and the royals take a 6-3 lead that's a
good plate appearance by mr oliveiras
very productive absolutely
there's a live drive
[Music]
bullet off the bat there josh bell
three hits last night two more hits
tonight i wouldn't let him take bad at
practice for a while
stomach
gets
newman
[Music]
way outside and that is just
the third walk enjoyed by holy paris
this year and the bases will be loaded
again
ball four and that will drive in the
royal's seventh run
well you know derek sheldon his manager
he gave him every opportunity to
see if he could right the ship but with
two outs he can't finish it off and the
pirates will bring on their fourth
pitcher of the evening and his
left-hander sam howard has two hits off
trevor williams
and this very long bottom of the seventh
comes to an end 7-3 kc
it's like they're trying to get back to
their world series days that those
strong bullpens they had
and look at this
he is going to be
safe
down
four
one out in the eighth
and frazier with a roller
he'll get an rbi and the pirates are
running closer because of the
aggressiveness of gonzales
he stayed at first that ground ball is a
double play
stayed with it
in the air alex gordon and the royals
have won five straight for the first
time this year merrifield goes deep
monday
with another home run
and salvador perez
well the royals 2-0 with him back in
that lineup